i go over to his house and he's with a
bunch of his boys and they're all on
craigslist and they're looking up
schemes of how to catch parrots because
you can make apparently like five to six
hundred dollars per [ __ ] carrot and i
remember they had a ploy of getting
super soakers and getting the uh the
wings of the parrots all wet so it'd be
hard for them to fly and then they could
catch them did it work i don't even know
where i heard that i never looked into
it
[Laughter]
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast that's a brand
new this is a [ __ ] [ __ ] year
where it comes to north korean podcast
everybody gonna die a fireplace
if you have a lunch you're lucky
if you have a breakfast you don't live
in north korea hello everybody we have
nick the ear here
one wonton ear at a time
and here we have patrick the deadbeat
dad
[Applause]
that's the worst wrestler of all time
all the time
cigarettes
pick up my daughter again
with the flask in his
you're hungry again did you eat
yesterday
[ __ ]
dab that should be your whole stick dude
i like that that should be the stick
that should be the whole yeah we're in
the new podcast now and it's kind of a
blessing and i was telling these guys
earlier that uh i have had the worst
situation with the [ __ ] biggest
[ __ ] of a landlord in my life
and that's why we're in this new space
by the way if you're dealing with shitty
landlords [ __ ] them and i'm not saying
listen
i'm not saying anything racial right
but maybe you should maybe you should
say something racial
but listen i'll say this i'll say this
i have a friend who's indian
right and i told him about my situation
and this is what he said to me i go yeah
my landlord he goes what ethnicity is
she i was like she's indian he goes why
the [ __ ] would you rent from an indian
person oh wow and he is indian
and i was like why he goes you know why
bro it's like it was gonna well when we
first rented from her
we no tell us why why why because they
their culture and their food is amazing
that's why and it gives you diarrhea
every now and then
it spills out like the truth
so originally we were dealing with the
landlord who was this you know chinese
lady which by the way same thing as
indian just different different shades
of color and so
she was she was perfectly fine and i
guess she fired her and then we found
out that the the landlord was gonna take
over so i met the landlord and she was
super cool at first guess what happened
so our year contract ended up
and we were she asked us if we're gonna
go month to month or we're gonna extend
for another year i said well we're going
to figure it out but we we love this
place but let's just go month to month
for now and she goes cool she sends us a
contract and the rent is 300 more
doesn't even tell us just send us a new
contract and so kind of [ __ ] up mario
looks at the contract and writes her
back says hey is this correct and she
goes yeah it is i'm like okay [ __ ] how
about you i don't know talk to us yeah
right maybe a little email write it out
or something but she just says the
contract and she just goes oh by the way
because of inflation blah blah blah
inflation
know
we have to uh the the uh the landscaping
people cost a lot more money so we have
to raise the rent that's fine
maybe [ __ ] tell us also and so i
wrote back to i was like hey
uh i understand that you can raise rent
and you just raised it by the california
maximum which during pandemic nobody did
that yeah that's [ __ ] up kind of
[ __ ] up i was like on average and i
asked other friends too who were renting
out their homes i was like how much did
you raise the rent or like well it's
pandemic we didn't raise it at all and
the most one of my friend rented two
percent at most and and i told him like
well she raised it by like six percent
they're like damn that's [ __ ]
aggressive like that's a lot especially
without discussing it with you guys
first yeah so you know i was going back
and forth with this lady
and then she would just like she wrote
to mariel hey oh by the way we should
probably charging you more rent this
place is actually worth like 4500 a
month
and then she goes you should ask your
husband because he would know about this
stuff more than you oh
oh wow
you females don't know anything so she
basically
explained to my wife and first of all
wow i wasn't even that mad until
marielle was like did you see what she
wrote to me i was like what will she
what'd she write to you yeah let me see
that phone and i see that email and i
read the email and i'm like
it's not that bad yeah and then she goes
i can't even deal with this she just
mansplained to me and she's a woman she
should know about and i was like yeah
i started getting high skill and damage
i started getting hyped
so she started getting me all hyped and
i got so [ __ ] mad i [ __ ] you not
my nose bled because my blood pressure
was oh
so as i was writing you got to see a
doctor like the girl from stranger
things yeah you're like stranger things
11 dude you're [ __ ] about to blow up
so
can you start levitating let me tell you
this [ __ ] so i'm writing this email
right and we're going back and forth and
she's just kind of coming i was like
hold on a second 4 500 a month i did one
zillow search looked up the whole area
and i showed her what 4 500 a month can
get you in this area and she goes well
you know our place is bigger we have
this [ __ ] let me tell you something i'm
gonna post photos in this in this video
about how stupid our [ __ ] place is
number one all the walls are concrete so
dumb dude [ __ ] stupid as [ __ ] yeah
one earthquake we're dead yeah die
number two she built this fireplace that
takes up i don't know 40 of the [ __ ]
living room it's for luxury bro that's
why you get to upcharge because it's
it's it's beautiful like this look at
this fireplace it's tiny exactly so
small for ants
who made this place place this fireplace
in a convenient area
dude another thing this place by the way
dumb as [ __ ]
there's another fireplace in the master
bedroom that covers i don't know 50 of
the bedroom once again
luxury dude who doesn't want to go to
sleep with a fireplace on ridiculous
that's a fire hazard probably that's not
a firehouse crazy
crazy
on top of that when we moved into this
place
no fresh paint whatsoever i have photos
of so she painted the wall two different
yellows four different browns and then
two different blues in the room you
gotta have variety david the worst
combination of all four so i wrote to
her and so when we were going to leave
right i said listen three different
yellows three different yeah this place
needs three different blues yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] and so
she didn't paint the place didn't sound
like that though and so mario
thank god for her she took a photo of
all the the paint fuck-ups when we first
moved in and it was never fixed but i
was like [ __ ] it's okay we're gonna
move in we'll just did you paint the
podcast room too yeah so we repainted
everything right and so when i'm gonna
leave i'm gonna repaint it a fresh white
and she writes back she goes oh before
you leave i want you to repaint the
place exactly how it was before we moved
in
three yellows i don't even know where to
find those yellows
you know i'm like and i wrote back
together i was like excuse me you never
gave us a fresh a coat of paint at all
we had to paint this place yeah so i'll
paint it white you know clean everything
fresh clean and she goes no you have to
return it back to the way that i gave it
to you i was like lady
you [ __ ] up the whole house you
painted all over the trim i had to pay
someone to repaint the the trim in the
whole house
so she wants me to repaint the place the
same color that she painted it because
she likes it that way i was like i will
repaint your home if you painted the
home before i moved in but you trashed
the place and i fixed it and she goes no
that's a taste preference you cut back i
will find where you live and i will
murder you not even you i know you have
a son i'm going to beat the [ __ ] out of
your son and he deserves it yeah because
your mother is a [ __ ]
yeah i agree i agree and also she's out
of mad men because she's [ __ ] thinks
women don't know [ __ ] about her
she's like women can't vote what are you
talking about
just to let you know your wife she's an
idiot
she doesn't know how business works [ __ ]
this lady dude
she doesn't even have a thick accent by
the way she's just perfectly no no she
does he has perfect english
or he was just perfect i'm just big bad
racial right now
but
so i'm literally telling my buddy this
is the voice world and he was like
blaming it on me he goes it's your fault
she's indian you know our people he goes
you know our people you shouldn't run
from us but she was super cool at first
but the moment that she tried to raise
rent and i was like this is unreasonable
yeah by the way her husband stepped into
the email and he was like trying to calm
everything down because he knew his wife
was acting like an [ __ ] but then
after that we just we decided to leave
and so i told her i was like you know
what this conversation is done i'll see
you in person when you come here face to
face and you talk to me well and so nice
talk square and then she wrote back she
goes well uh i won't be coming i'm just
gonna send management over i'm like no
no you come here and you say the
offensive [ __ ] [ __ ] you send on this
email to my face yeah that's right and
then we'll see what's up here about the
whooper [ __ ] ass no what i'm going to
do is i'm going to get butt naked in
front of her it's like look my wife got
to see this every night so now you do
and then she gives you your whole
deposit back yeah exactly you should've
took a [ __ ] on the floor before you left
and just she's ridiculous are you gonna
do any like
potentially petty stuff before you leave
oh what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna put a
sticky note on every [ __ ] area of the
house like my buddy ed did before he
leave this place left his place and tell
everybody what's wrong with this place
number one because all the walls are
concrete
by the way it's going to be ice cold
inside it's going to be 30 degrees
colder inside than it is outside i
didn't know you could do that i didn't
know you could make a whole house like i
don't think that's legal yeah because i
don't think yeah i don't [ __ ] know
but it's it's all concrete and we found
out the first day when i tried to put a
picture frame up and it destroyed my
hammer
damn dude
they had no [ __ ] ideas that's kind of
unheard of she refuses to fix the toilet
refuses to do anything so i'm like we're
done and i'm gonna make sure whoever
moves in there knows how [ __ ] shitty
this place is yeah and [ __ ] the peacocks
in our area yeah yeah
losers bro
they're [ __ ] useless especially in
arcadia all they do is probably cause
car accidents i bet there's a stat about
all the car accidents that are caused by
peacocks but the arcadia government is
[ __ ] covering it up covering it up
yeah because he's [ __ ] conspiracy nah
it's about the peacock conspiracy though
i think originally the peacocks were
protected in arcadia i don't think they
are anymore good i think you could just
straight kill she's on site no it's just
something
i saw you yesterday on my
taking his [ __ ] and they yell like dudes
[ __ ] them dude they just go wow like
it's just some guy yelling at you like
when we first moved into arcadia i
thought children were screaming around
in the area yeah
yeah that's just peacock all day and
then pasadena got parrots yeah they do
those [ __ ] are loud
where they're from mexico uh-oh are they
you know what
they are it's a really funny story the
first time i hung out with patrick like
i went to his house because we were gym
friends and then he made we made that
transition of like hey come over here
lovers i go over to his house and he's
with a bunch of his boys probably like
21
and they're all on craigslist and
they're looking up schemes of how to
catch parrots
and sell them on craigslist because you
can make apparently like five to six
hundred dollars per [ __ ] parrot and i
remember they had a ploy of getting
super soakers
and wetting and getting the uh the wings
of the parrots all wet so it'd be hard
for them to fly and then they could
catch them did it work
never once never once did it work it
didn't work once also the figure 700 i
don't even know because it was my idea i
don't even know where i heard that i
never looked into it it was your idea
[Laughter]
hold on high school we're gonna start
this parent business let me tell you
something right now if you don't believe
pat is mexican that is the most mexican
thing i've ever heard in my life hey
like palada you know if you like it like
a super soaker and [ __ ] if you spray the
wings they can't fly
all right we thought they'd get heavy or
like we're gonna mix
a mixture of water and oil like cooking
oil okay to like to weigh them down
uh where do you catch them wrap them up
and then i don't know i guess the pet
store but like i said they could have
actually been worth 25 someone just said
700 one day and i was like oh [ __ ]
that's a lot of money and we tried like
twice and didn't catch anything they
don't ever come down to the floor
they're always up in trees they never
come down that's like jungle bird [ __ ]
so i looked up chuckle bird [ __ ] i
looked up david knows the reasons why so
look check it out so i looked it up
because at first when i was listening to
these creatures i'm like they sound like
parrots but this is california so
somebody smuggled these [ __ ] in right
and apparently in mexico they're like
going extinct
so they're either there's there's not
that many in mexico now or they're
completely extinct over there but over
here they thrive because of all like the
food and all the little creatures so
that's why there's so many in pasadena
that's why yup so some [ __ ] guy
probably got a super soaker with some
oil
hey come here
boom got it and brought them over to
california but now they're just there's
like hundreds of them here how did they
catch them back in the day
i couldn't do it with a super soaker so
how what were they doing you know they
didn't have super snacks bro they got
nets are that high in the sky how come
you guys never just i don't know put out
like food we did do that too they're
hella smart you actually really executed
this plan we tried wow i didn't know i
thought it was just a theory at that
point no no we tried i had no idea you
guys went to the field we went to
college
we went to khaled's house because he had
easy access to a big tree
didn't work out it was like this get
rich
quick it was so dumb with parrots of all
things
what happens if you had like 20 parrots
and then you guys went to the pet store
and they're like oh yeah these are like
dude
yeah yeah are really greasy
what made you think that you could catch
these birds well i mean uh
not my intelligence it was uh like
i don't know we just it was just
something someone said and we were 20 or
whatever and we're like yeah
and now you know what i think about no
thought whatsoever i've never talked
about it but i think about it very often
honestly i think about it i think about
it sometimes and i get embarrassed like
i get really embarrassed i'd be
embarrassed i'm embarrassed right now
i'm just obviously parents i think of
patrick that's why all the cool kids
stole drugs as well trying to sell paris
and [ __ ]
it's probably way easier to start
selling weed than to start selling nah
you should sell it very easy dude
we're gonna bring
i don't know who you're trying to sell
paris to
but nick somebody on the street and
you're going to sell him a parent i want
to see this [ __ ]
amen
[Laughter]
hey man
uh yeah hey what's up we are at vaughn's
right now we're shopping for turkey
burgers but uh do you like parrots dude
excuse me do i like parrots parrots are
dope they're colorful they're beautiful
uh they talk to you yeah are you
divorced are you married
i'm married but i don't think i wanna
parrot at all dude you could make him
say talk [ __ ] to your wife like you
could do dope [ __ ] like that
no i don't want a parrot in my house
[ __ ] you dude
this podcast is brought to you by better
help online therapy we talk about better
help a lot on this show and this month
we are discussing some of the stigmas
around mental health and i know a lot of
you out there think that you have to
wait to go to therapy before you know
when things become unbearable but let me
tell you something therapy is a tool to
utilize before things get worse and it
can honestly help you avoid a lot of
these lows and many people think that
therapy is you know for so-called crazy
people but therapy doesn't mean
something's wrong with you it means you
recognize that all humans have emotions
and we need to learn how to control them
and not avoid them i've been using
better help for quite a while now that's
why we still continue to talk about it
on this podcast and you know honestly
just having somebody to talk to where i
feel that number one it's in a safe
space and i don't feel judged helps me
to really collect my thoughts and kind
of control these crazy emotions because
honestly we all know social media and
all these outside influences tend to
weigh us down and we feel like sometimes
we don't have anybody to talk to about
these experiences because we feel weak
and that's where better help has helped
me out a lot better help is customized
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat sessions with your
therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in person
therapy and you can be matched with the
therapist in under 48 hours give it a
try and see why over 2 million people
have used better help online therapy
this podcast is sponsored by better
healthy genius brain listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
genius that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-dot-com
genius you know what actually now that i
think about it it's like yeah what who
because how many people have you ever
met in your life like you can count on
one hand if you've ever met somebody
that actually owned a pair by the way
they're all over everybody i know that's
owned a parrot mexican really mexican
people love birds
they i've seen mexican birds but not
parrots dudes yeah mexican people love
parrots like all chickens
three
three people that own a parent and
they're mexican
like the you know those big gray ones
yeah yeah i had a homegirl that owned
one of those big [ __ ] gray ones and
had somebody else who owned one of those
colorful green and blue ones you know i
know a couple mixings with a parrot as
well well the whole actually birdcage i
just love birds man they're such weird
but like having a bird is such like says
a lot about you i feel like like why the
[ __ ] you got a burst i just find it so
funny that you somehow got your friends
to go into the scheme with you where you
just like close the pitch
you don't even believe like 700 dollars
do you even believe in the efficacy of
having a bird as well no none of your
homies were like i just heard that's
dumb no they were all on board we were
all i remember idiots nick was on board
nick was i almost hired it was collect
it was a collective of friends that are
in there and i was like i was like yeah
that does sound like a great idea nick
was on board too you know actually now i
remember this that was down i went home
and i told my dad about it and he's like
no
that's a terrible idea he's like what if
what if that's illegal what if you get
arrested and i was like oh yeah you're
right and then never thought about it
ever again yeah i find it so shameful
that he was talking [ __ ] to you like he
didn't he was in on the plan you're a
piece of [ __ ] he was awake hold on you
wanted to sell the parrots too so what
the [ __ ] were you thinking it was my
first time and he had a very good pitch
and i was like yeah that sounds like a
good idea
very simple it was a 700 i was
passionate though i really was pat i
remember being passionate and the whole
room the whole room was like let's do
this
this works everybody collective did you
know like the scene of wolf of wall
street it was like that yeah just about
parrots instead of stocks parrot oil and
super soakers that was those were the
talking points i was thinking oh my god
is so hilarious it's a terrible plan the
only reason why i'm laughing is because
first of all what is your super soaker
powered by do you know how high those
birds are they're at the they're
literally at the tallest trees in
pasadena there's no you need like fire
it's all
trajectory even see that we have to talk
about today's podcast
this is like more business
so recently
and i had some time to think about this
right just because number one
uh
i like joe rogan's podcast i i i listen
to it
intermittently not everything i think
what i like about his podcast is that if
you don't like what he's talking about
he's gonna he's gonna put out like six
or seven throughout the week so you can
pick and choose which one you're you're
interested in
so recently
joe rogan has been getting flamed yeah
people coming after him people are
coming after him and so throughout the
pandemic in the last two years he has
been somebody who has been rather
skeptical about the information that has
been given to us about
covid right which i think a lot of us
definitely
are very skeptical skeptical scalable
skeptical
yes and the reason why is because you
know the coronavirus was so [ __ ] new
and we've seen the information change
constantly which is which is given
because it was the novel corona virus we
don't know anything about the nature of
science exactly these diseases and so
what rogan has been doing he has been
inviting
people who are relative experts in the
field specifically he invited somebody
who was a very well-known virologist and
so when somebody says are they a doctor
doctors don't mean [ __ ] in this scenario
we're i'm not they don't i'm not saying
that but i'm saying a virologist has a
lot more credibility to talk about yes
it is what they are known for and the
specific person that he brought into his
podcast has about like nine patents on
mrna vaccines which essentially is what
the code vaccine is
so
this i listened to this podcast so
robert malone yes and he was talking
about
how relative dangerous these myocarditis
yeah they're they're not tried and true
yet right and and how fast it's been
given to us is a little bit alarming
which
hearing this from somebody who
once again has nine patents on mrna
vaccines it's pretty scary it's you know
he's giving alternative information
alternative facts to what the news is
giving us right
so because of that a lot of people have
been
you know calling rogan an anti-fascist
and i think he's vaccinated yeah i think
he is yeah but he won't ever say it
though like he kind of does
like toe the line a little bit when it
comes to the covet stuff like
part of the reason what you said about
the co about joe rogan why he's so great
is because he does have a variety of
guests
and then if you don't like talking about
mma you have another guest that's
talking about whatever the hell you want
to hear but the reason why i kind of
stopped listening to the rogan exp
podcast as much is because
i just didn't like how you would always
just bring up coven or like just just
out of nowhere just to kind of get
people talking about it and sometimes it
was just too much and i just like ah bro
i don't want to hear him kind of lean on
with this kobe stuff especially when you
have like an mma guy it's like bro i
don't want to hear about this just talk
about whatever you guys want to talk
about and if it comes up organically in
the conversation that's great but that
was part of the other reason he was like
very strong
with yeah yeah yeah and i think
rightfully so though like it's because
it's
huge you know it's like a big deal like
it's still affecting a lot of people's
lives but uh
that dude the robert malone one uh
like the thing is is like
just it's good to have all the opinions
out there and as adults we can all just
kind of [ __ ] listen to it and be like
i'll just i'll take gather the
information i want and make my own
decisions you know i mean like and i
think the interesting thing is about
that pot or just what people are saying
and they're like
you know he's spreading because this is
the hot word it's misinformation right
but then in my mind i'm thinking
because i'm not a die hard rogan fan
right
but in my mind i'm telling myself what
is misinformation when it's coming from
the mouth of somebody who is a
virologist
who is very well known in this subject
we have some credibility who has a lot
of not even a little bit a [ __ ] ton of
credibility in this space so what makes
people say that that's misinformation i
think the the the thing that i dislike
right because once again i'm vaccinated
right i have nothing i i am vaccinated
i think
the problem that i have with a lot of
people when they say words like
misinformation or they get super hyped
up about a topic that even they don't
know about they don't do any type of
research and they go on these long
diatribes and they can't point it out
what's the misinformation and why is it
misinformation go and most people would
be like uh
they have they have no idea what they're
talking about because what they do is
they they have a subject and they'll use
something else to discredit you that has
nothing to do with this topic if you are
not vaccinated i have read so many
tweets i've read so many instagram posts
about calling people murderers if they
are not vaccinated and one of the
interesting things that i have to you
know people have to recognize that's why
i call patrick all the time dude i'm
vaccinated murderer murderer idiot
chiller
deadbeat flash drinking dab
right parrot catching very catching
so they'll use these like they'll use
something like these hot takes on this
buzz words yeah these buzzwords to make
people feel terrible about this stuff
right but
you don't know a lot about this virus or
you know as much about this virus as
much as i do for real dude right and the
fact that you can go out and call people
murderers and call people just selfish
or whatever because they don't want to
take a vaccine that they don't know
about
i think it's valid right and the weird
thing is is that okay let's talk about
this [ __ ] mayor garcetti
he held his breath you know
like shut the [ __ ] up dude there wasn't
even a mask in sight yeah yeah i don't
give a [ __ ]
mayor garcetti is the most hood
[ __ ] i've ever met in my life
because only a hood dude would say that
as a reason
like really think about it like this if
we just flip it up a little bit okay so
i'm taking a picture right and somebody
goes hey you're not facts
why do you have your mask down hey bruh
i was holding my breath
that's a good explanation and the fact
that he's the mayor and he said that
publicly is the most insane thing i've
ever heard in my life when no one's
getting mad at magic johnson you know
because he's dope yeah yeah yeah he's
definitely
well and also he's not the one imposing
the rules yeah it's like magic johnson
was the one imposing the rules what the
[ __ ] what did maggie johnson do also he
was on the picture he just didn't have a
mask yeah yeah yeah i think he was in a
difficult way yeah he survived he could
do whatever yeah he did survive enough
yeah what's coming
aids
i don't care yeah that dude beat aids
yeah
that beat and give him a shot he's the
man
dude i can't believe mayor garcia said
that and newsom i think said the same i
can't believe they actually thought that
that would that's like out of south but
also just take the l bro yeah just be
like yeah i wasn't wearing a mask nobody
was that's a chappelle sketch right now
that's a sketch yeah that's what i'm
saying it's like a parody there's no way
they really said that i thought it was a
joke when i first thought i was like oh
that's funny so straight up when i saw
people posting it on the story i thought
it was like one of those onion articles
yeah so it was hilarious
i giggled and i moved on and then two
days later i was talking to a buddy of
mine and he goes dude your [ __ ] mayor
is weird i'm like what are you talking
about
he was like
he was talking about him not wearing
hair holding his breath in the picture i
was like dude that's an onion article he
was like no it's not an onion article he
legit said that and i was this i was so
pissed so he had to hold his like
hypothetically he had to be masked magic
johnson what's up magic johnson
and then not know what's up after you
can't talk to magic after 10 seconds and
then when he gets 10 feet away he has to
blow out because the germs are in his
nose
he has to like depress you know he's
stupid what a dumbass what a [ __ ]
that dude is a weirdo he's weird that
dude's weird the fact that he before he
just purges bro he actually thought that
people were gonna be
you know what that's my man you know his
face looks like a purge mask like you
put on during the purge like you know
it's richard nixon or whatever you could
like put his face on and be like damn i
guess gonna kill a homeless dude for
sure i wasn't i don't want to be like
the cool guy here shut up i was never on
mayor garcetti's train bro i never liked
him you voted for him you wanna know why
what so tiffany had a uh graduation at
ucla and he was the speaker he was the
keynote speaker this [ __ ] was 45
minutes late wow
that's what i'm saying i'm like what the
[ __ ] is this why this he's not even
graduating why why why do we have to
listen to mayor garcetti speak yeah
about what what college
he didn't i'll be 100 what does the
mayor do that's what i'm saying the
reason why his breath yeah he holds his
breath and he had to use this another
lame stupid excuse just like he was
holding his breath he was saying that he
was late because of a memorial from a
firefighter oh yeah right yeah sure what
what's the firefighter's name
exactly exactly
lies there's a mask holding his breath
now he lies about fireman's [ __ ]
memorials his scrapbook jerky
today the only way i would vote for
mayor garcetti again is if he [ __ ]
had an italian accent yeah you're a fake
italian you should have ours just do it
i was holding my breath
oh like super talented
guy right there it just says dishes he
just says italian dish menu
honestly i would vote for him i think
too like yeah if you had an italian
accent i bet you i honestly no joke
people would act like if you know when
they show the polls there'd be like 15
people that actually voted for him if he
did that even
oh
what are you talking about
you should you should break down the joe
rogan story uh like you're a talent
perfect about the n word and the
controversy
[Music]
yeah yeah is that a song and then people
had an italian song or something
it's not even italian people would be
enlightened they'd be like oh [ __ ] i
never thought of it like that
they're like they're like i get it now
they have a [ __ ]
but
okay let's go into that bang so after so
joe rogan did something pretty cool
after the whole spotify thing you know
talking about misinformation
he actually went on instagram and he put
it on spotify
to kind of talk about what's going on
yeah and he did a very good job talking
about misinformation i think the point a
point that he brought up that was really
cool was you know a lot of the stuff
that people were saying that was
misinformation in the beginning turned
out to be true for example cloth mass
cloth masks don't do anything when it
comes to this virus right and people
were saying this and i do remember two
years ago when the pandemic first
started if you said that publicly people
will call you a murderer they would have
said that you were you didn't care about
public health even though the facts were
true right and this is what he's talking
about a lot of the stuff because of this
you know media fervor and everybody's so
quick to call somebody um a
quote-unquote a murderer that when
people have alternative thoughts say hey
these cloth masks don't work people are
just quick to dismiss you and it turned
out to be true but nobody's addressing
that right nobody's talking about this
virus being so new that a lot of this
information that we don't know about and
when it turns out that it's not true
nobody wants to mention it it just
doesn't exist yeah so that's part of the
main issue why like people don't trust
anything the government says like they
never come back on like what they're
saying and or put the information in
context at least yeah or just say like
hey guys we're still figuring this out
as we go new information is gonna be
out and sometimes that changes over a
period of time yeah and they're not
doing that and it sucks but no they're
not honest at all my lovely genius farts
this podcast you guys already know
is brought to you by babel i'm all about
learning new languages and i'm not just
saying that you know
that my lady speaks i don't know
mandarin korean japanese and english and
i'm trying to keep up but right now
because i live in los angeles i'm trying
to learn how to speak espanol i'm not
going to butcher it right now because
i'm still on the way of learning because
i want to talk back and forth with all
my compadres and it'll be super super
fun you know pat on the podcast he's
mexican and he speaks spanish and i'm
trying to talk [ __ ] to his face in a
very fluent type of way not only is
learning a new language a fun and
engaging new hobby you can use it while
you check off traveling
more from your list the whole babel
process is addictively fun fast and easy
and babel teaches bite-sized language
lessons for real world use babel's
15-minute lessons make it the perfect
way to learn a new language on the go
with babel you can choose from 14
languages including spanish french
italiano and sherman so
you guys have a whole bunch of options
and the cool thing about babel is the
fact that they teach you how to speak
the language like regular people speak
it i know that you guys take has taken
language classes in high school and they
always teach you this like jargon that's
super textbook that nobody uses and it's
freaking embarrassing
but with babel you'll be able to learn
how to speak the language
conversationally right now when you
purchase a three-month battle
subscription you'll get an additional
three months for free that's six months
for the price of three just go to
babel.com and use promo code gb that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com
code gb babble language for life and you
know the honest i mean let's just be
honest the fact that we could go into a
restaurant and then we have a mask and
then we sit down we take it off and then
suddenly we're safe it's it's it's a
little ridiculous it is it's it's it's
pretty [ __ ] dumb at this point just
have people come into the restaurant
without the mask because once we're
eating it's pretty much done it doesn't
matter yeah it literally does matter
that's not me being this [ __ ] weird
anti-information like this is just a
hundred percent facts isn't it crazy
that that's controversial though
literally what you just said was the
most common sense [ __ ] ever people were
to come after me now yeah they go oh
yeah [ __ ] murder i knew you were
north korean from your [ __ ] little face
yeah yeah yeah that was my comment
i left that comment yeah
i don't know i love italian people dude
you know what my favorite thing about
italian maybe my new favorite accent you
do thank you dude that's pretty [ __ ]
good my favorite thing about italian
people is how much they love food and
when you [ __ ] up pasta everybody freaks
the [ __ ] out
have you seen those compilations of like
italians freaking out when they break
pasta in the pot you gotta show me that
because [ __ ] that [ __ ] makes me lovely
and i'm like yo these guys are really
italian i thought it was gonna be like
like east coast italian cause i think
that's what we think as americans we
think like oh from new york like i'm
walking here like that's what we think
italian is but like italian from italy
from the motherland so different so
different dude there was a video of this
guy
he was trying to correct people on how
to say mozzarella
but because he's east coast italian his
version of italian is is this
amalgamation of just like this cultural
evolution that happened in america yeah
so he was trying to correct people he
goes hey it's not mozzarella it's sorel
and then another
but he doesn't [ __ ] know it's not
that yeah so another italian person did
a video of his video going isa
and it was super mario
i want to watch italian content from now
on
people and how die-hard they are but
when you watch them cook bro yeah
there's something to it when you have a
pasta you put a lot of salt in the water
because it should taste like a horse
[Laughter]
subscribers yeah
italians out there
yes but just to bring it back to the
topic back to rogan
did something cool
he did something really that's where you
were but what he did really cool was the
spotify thing and he was talking about
how
you know he's going to do a better job
of maybe inviting people who
aren't so
um counter
what's the word counter information just
on on one side of the spectrum of the
argument so he'll bring somebody else in
after just to balance it out that's a
great idea because you know a lot of
people were like giving [ __ ] to robert
malone and
like all that podcast and i think part
of it is fair because some of the claims
he was saying i saw another uh like
breaking point did a really good job of
getting another md who's a specialist in
the field and then just contextualized
what robert mullen was saying to just
make more sense because he had like a
lot of really crazy claims about like
myocarditis that may not be
scientifically i guess um
agreed upon you know honestly in the so
they had another scientist come on the
doctor a working practitioner and break
down some of the claims and just say
like look
we're saying that if you get the third
booster the more increase of a vaccine
you get there tends to be a higher
chance of myocarditis in men from 18 to
31.
so by with that information he's like
it's not a question of getting
vaccinated or not it's a matter of how
do we do it safely to make sure we lower
the risk of this incidence of happening
and he and then he broke it down saying
like if you're a young male between the
ages of 18 to 30 whatever 35 maybe and
you have two shots already maybe don't
get the the booster maybe you don't need
to get the booster and that's very
[ __ ] important exactly and that's
what we need right we need more of that
because unfortunately for robert malone
right like
you see it where
when he talks about virology and he
talks about the vaccine stuff because
he's a doctor people will only listen to
what they want confirmation on and use
that as a narrative of saying like this
doctor said this so this must be true
but
he has to i think he should have done a
better job of being a little more
balanced with what the claims he was
saying yes of like this is not a 100
definitive but there's evidence that
could prove and point that this may be
true but we still don't know and i feel
like when you have experts on like that
and that talk with this type of uh
cadence and this rhythm then
maybe he won't get um what's what i'm
looking for uh like
yeah cancel because all his his twitter
got shut down
his uh youtube that's kind of crazy too
they shouldn't do that right yeah they
should crazy that's what i'm saying like
that is that can't fly either because
then it's like then it feeds more into
they're trying to shut them down because
he's saying it just makes people feel
more dig deeper and deeper
they sink their teeth in a little
it causes this this cycle of what people
keep talking about misinformation when
when we can get there are people out
there that have way more balanced views
on the topic and they just need to be
heard and that's what joe rogan's good
for joe rogan is that guy where he could
bring these experts on and provide a
better opinion or just to ease the minds
of the listeners so they they're not
always like what the [ __ ] do i do do i
get the vaccine do i not get the vaccine
[ __ ] establishment like it just keeps
going on and on and it sucks because
now joe rogan's getting dragged for it
yeah and that's my opinion on it i think
he and but also too like when you said
when he says you know i think we could
do a better job i could do a better job
of getting more balanced gas i'm like
that does it for me yeah right i love it
all you got to do yeah that's it that's
clear and have a space for open
discussion because that's what they need
you know because he's done it before
where he had two people of opposing uh
ideologies come on the podcast and
battle it out i wouldn't say battle but
just kind of go back they have a
discussion yeah yeah they do that in the
fitness ones all the time where they
have like a keto guy and then they have
like a regular like whatever diet and
they they hash it out but but you can
kind of extrapolate a little bit from
those interviews especially when we get
certain fitness people on he kind of he
kind of gets some people that might be
more on the outside of fringe that may
not be
100 with the evidence base and kind of
what's out there but then again you have
to take that with a grain of salt too
but i don't know man it just sucks that
he's getting dragged for i think i think
it's a little more insidious though i
think there because it's not just like
random people getting outraged i think
it really is like the machine coming
after him because he's a threat dude
he's a threat to all the media and this
becomes it's like he's threat to
politicians now he's threat like he's a
threat to a lot of powerful people so i
think it's more than just like people
because you'll see the people that want
to cancel them like even for what we're
about to talk about but they're like
he's dangerous like he could be doing
this he's doing that it's like yo we're
not little kids like we can [ __ ]
we're adults you know if i choose to
listen to this i can listen to this i
can make up my own [ __ ] mind like you
said he brings on the opposing that's
that's that's all we need like just
let's hear both sides some people he
might get convinced by this side some
people might convinced by that side but
that's just the way it [ __ ] is dude
and that's just the way it works and
i've always said this too when you
listen to something as
as free form as a podcast it is your job
as a listener when we talk about things
that quote unquote let's say even for me
i think are facts just take it with a
grain of salt and if it's something that
you're going to take away from and apply
in your life
do your own research and make sure that
you fact check me fact check anybody on
a podcast because at the end of the day
even when it comes to joe rogan's
podcast or this podcast we're just
shooting [ __ ] you're just a fly on the
wall
listening into a conversation of two top
three tards and that's really what it is
that's the branding yeah and you know
what in all honesty there are people who
listen to this podcast that disagree
with a lot of the things that we talk
about and they're welcome just as much
as people who agree with us because it's
really just an entertaining conversation
right now
like for example when i
first listened to
rogue's podcast and he was talking about
things about weight loss and all this
stuff and he has somebody named dr
rhonda patrick and she is an expert in
her field and she talks about all these
little small case studies when it comes
to like uh certain vitamins or whatever
i after i listened to that podcast i was
like this is very interesting i didn't
go and start taking all the supplements
that she suggested i went this is a
freaking idiot and i went and i decided
to look up what this stuff does to your
body how much do you need it and then i
made a choice for myself people forget
that you have the option of choice it is
your choice to really go ahead and you
know understand the information that's
coming at you and then apply it to your
life nobody's forcing you to do this
this is a podcast we have no boss there
is nobody there's no network filtering
and screening the things that i'm saying
so with everything that i say on this
podcast take it with a grain of salt
especially when it comes to joe rogan is
because he has such a huge platform
right and so the next thing that we're
going to talk about too is that this is
the weird thing
so we had this conversation uh or the
world is having this conversation
somebody made a compilation clip of joe
rogan patrick patrick riley
his name is patrick.t
so this guy
of joe
rogan using the n-word and so joe rogan
on spotify got his second imagine making
his opposition to be the guy that went
through literally a thousand episodes so
many [ __ ] episodes how long did that
take how much research yeah how long is
the video is that like two minutes i
heard it's long i heard it was like 10
minutes a lot of enemies so
there's a lot of envelopes a lot bro so
it can't be 10 minutes long dude it's 79
minutes long yeah so joe
it's two hours another podcast
no fat on the video either yeah no fat
no ads bro no ads edward edwards
and so whether or not we're talking
about context or not right and joe rogan
also um
he addresses he said that
no matter what the context is when he
looks at these videos and he saw the
video himself he cringed sure because he
was ashamed of it right and like
yeah he's like oh that was a good one
replay that one
back to back right he's leaving time
stamps oh that was a good one that was a
good one
capitalization he apologized for it and
he talked about the context in which it
was used and i'm pretty sure that a lot
of people if you're not being dishonest
you probably use that word in those
contexts as well and i'm pretty sure
that you could find years ago videos
like i remember too when people would
reference these words like like say for
example right like hey so this guy said
this this and we're talking about
somebody who is racist and he used the n
word with the hard r we would never say
n word we would say this guy actually
said the word n-word with the heart r we
would say this in reference to the story
right but we wouldn't say it as if it
was us saying it right because yeah
exactly yeah and at the time it was
understood that it was okay but that
word gradually whether it was because
the internet or people were being more
outspoken for it made people feel a
certain way so now we don't do it
anymore and people are forgetting like
just contextualizing this that
even within the past five or six years
the evolution of where that word can be
used and not used has changed a lot and
you have to recognize that now it
doesn't change the fact that the way
that people feel about it they feel hurt
and that's completely valid nobody's
saying that [ __ ] right but when we look
at what happened to joe rogan why this
is coming out it looks like it's a hit
job it's like okay so joe rogan did a
good job of addressing what happened on
the spotify cases right cool he's free
well guess what i'm gonna go after him
again and i'm gonna find something to
cancel this guy because if it's not this
it's gonna be something else and that's
where i disagree this podcast is brought
to you by butcher box my friends my
lovely genius brain farts due to your
support we get to be sponsored by
butcher box i've actually been using
butcher box before i was even a sponsor
so this is just a match made in heaven
but your box is a subscription service
that takes the guesswork out of finding
high quality meet my friends no more
searching the grocery store for 100
grass-fed beef free-range organic
chicken wild-caught seafood and more
because their sourcing decisions are
made holistically keeping the farmer the
planet the animal and your family in
mind i love the stuff that i get from
birch box actually the other day
i decided that i wanted to go ahead and
make a bolognese and what does a
bolognese require some good ground beef
and the great thing about italian food
is is that there aren't an absorbent
amount of ingredients so the ingredients
that you do use in your dish do have to
speak for itself and the quality of meat
even when it comes to ground beef was so
delicious it made my bolognese a
freaking uh amazing every month
butcherbox ships a curated selection of
high quality meat right to your home
free shipping for the continental u.s no
antibiotics or added hormones and each
box contains between 8 to 14 pounds of
meat look this is your chance to never
have to shop for ground beef again
that's right butcher box is giving new
members free ground beef for life sign
up at butcherbox.com brain and get two
pounds of ground beef for free in every
order for the life of your membership
let's go log on to butcherbox.com
brain claim this deal
so because and by the way he addressed
this too
and he
made sure that people knew how ashamed
he was of the fact that he used this and
a lot of people who are in the black
community came in defensively he's like
look i met this guy he's not racist
i know this dude right all these other
maybe white comedians who say he's not
racist your opinion probably doesn't
matter as much
you know but people are
yo david goggins did the best version of
he goes hey i'm a friend of joe rogan
i'm a black man i've had those hard
words sent to me when he said it was he
wrong yeah he was wrong right is he
racist absolutely not
and i think that's fair that is fair he
used it and it was terrible is he racist
no and i think that's the most fair
version of what happened 100 so it's
coming back to the context thing like
yeah joe rogan was wrong but context
does it does matter you know and i mean
like you said um
like there's a difference between
[ __ ] like if i choke choking a woman
is bad right like that's a bad
you choke a lady bad right in bed you
want to make her come harder good guy
you know what i mean
like you could [ __ ] like so
but the thing is is like dude like
i don't know he was wrong but like yeah
like you said context does is important
you know yeah and i i think the weird
thing is is that
whoever's trying to do this to him and
his platform they think that people are
stupid yeah exactly so who do you think
is doing it huh who do you think it is
doing it
patrick reilly dude that's amazing i
didn't catch those goddamn parrots and
i've been bitter ever since goddammit
it's it's a weird thing to talk about
now where i you know i don't know how
many people are really catching on to
this but it's just a little odd that
this is the next thing that follows up
oh we didn't get to cancel him about the
covet thing yeah let's make sure that
he's not credible in any of his
platforms by finding something else to
take him down you don't have to be a joe
rogan fan you could even be a joe rogan
hater but the way that people are going
about this is pretty [ __ ] stupid and
it's dumb yeah and i dislike it right
especially when somebody like him
addresses it really well i would have an
issue with joe rogan if he did a video
he goes yeah i could use the word it was
okay back in the day i'd be like yo
you're kind of weird yeah right you know
right yo who has to give joe rogan a
pass dave chappelle dave shabbas to come
out and be like yo yeah giving joe rogan
a pass and do you think that stops all
the all the controversy i mean danielle
rawlins came out and he was like
y'all think he's racist i don't and
talk about a black man that's danielle
rollins that's ashley larry bro
that is a pillar of the black community
yeah he's the best but i really do think
it's a cnn thing man i really do think
it's like a it's a media thing i think
it's a media thing it's just because
it's so they're all it's the corporation
like they're all kind of involved like
politics corporations media so i think
it's the that machine trying to get rid
of him dude he's too much of a problem a
lot of people are making um comparisons
from now that like cnn their ratings
were through the roof when they would
just talk about trump all the time right
yeah [ __ ] on him whatever
and then now that they don't really have
trump anymore
a lot of people are making the argument
that like joe rogan is kind of being the
next target the next guy that they can
kind of come after and then while like i
hear nothing i hear everything about joe
rogan right now but i hear nothing about
the stuff in ukraine that's happening
the stuff with like russia you know and
it's like and even the gilley maxwell
stuff like it is interesting and you can
play conspiracy theory all you want but
it is interesting how you start to see
uh you notice certain trends that happen
that are right up in your face i'll tell
you this this whole joe rogan covet
thing
is even it's bigger news than the fact
that cnn
a supposedly accredited [ __ ] news
source decided to take one of his clips
they made him look like a zombie from
lord of the rings yeah right right yeah
with the filter with the whole filter
and they put that as a as a fact
that is that is not as egregious as joe
rogan who brings alternative thought
from experts
that to me is a problem and once again
i'm not really a conspiracy theorist but
when i saw that cnn did that and then
nobody's making a big deal of it shows
how
convicted people are already in their
thoughts of what they think about cobit
it doesn't matter about facts it doesn't
matter about this new information that's
coming out they are going to believe
what they want to believe it's religious
it's kind of religious it is very
religious and that's scary it's it is
scary
but it's weird as [ __ ] dude like people
are just so on their team that they're
just not i don't know what happened
where the breakdown happened but i think
trump had something to do with it
because he got people so riled up and he
got people scared that's what i noticed
is when people are afraid and if like
you give them kind of an outlet or a
team or something to hang on to like
they just kind of they turn into these
[ __ ] weirdos that we're still living
with today you know i think the
algorithm be [ __ ] people up dude i
think that has part of it too right
because it's like in your face all the
time and then it becomes of like why is
everybody talking about this yeah there
becomes that type of reaction with
certain groups of people but yeah it
just seems like everybody
people just want to be they don't want
to be challenged in their thought they
want to be challenging their own beliefs
i think and i think it's really hard i
think nowadays it's it's kind of worse
than ever because you see it in
different pockets in all communities
like it's interesting because in the
fitness community you see the same type
of thing like people are arguing about
stuff that like
doesn't really matter you know and it
becomes
like yeah it just it's just too much and
then you see that extrapolated out but
just now it's with covid and you kind of
flip whatever
topic there is in each community and
there's gonna be just so many people
just arguing about it over the little
minute details that kind of don't really
matter in the grand scheme of things i
mean at the end of the day what it's
really showing is that a lot of people
don't
really care that much about free thought
right and
and i say that because
the fact that nobody cares i wouldn't
say nobody but there's a
on the internet it seems like the vast
majority of sp specifically a lot of
like hyperliberal people
um they don't care about
just like your freedom being taken away
it's very odd to me and yeah it is crazy
and i know it sounds very exaggerated to
a lot of people but when somebody says
to me like hey
you this is a vaccine that we don't know
too much about but you have to take this
because i say so
it kind of freaks me out and once again
i'm [ __ ] fully
yeah i was [ __ ] nervous and it
doesn't and and the fact that people
just don't care about that they just go
okay not everybody but they say
well it's a vaccine we should just take
it well you know people in japan the
reason why they were so delayed with
taking the vaccine was because it was
the perfect vaccine it took so long to
perfect it there was japanese like years
years ago japan got [ __ ] wrecked by a
vaccine
because it wasn't like either thoroughly
tested or something like that and they
got [ __ ] by after that they're like
unless it's fully tried and true we're
not taking this [ __ ] vaccine yeah so
they were an example of somebody who
they're not against vaccines but they
want more evidence that this stuff will
work and it will protect them and it's
completely cool i think that's very fair
yeah completely cool like that's a very
common sense way of approaching the
situation yeah and i think that people
should just stop [ __ ] getting in
other people's faces who don't want to
take the vaccine and people who don't
want to take the vaccine should stop
calling people who do take the vaccine
[ __ ] idiots just find your own
[ __ ] business i mean and to go back
to the free thought thing it's not just
even with the vaccine it's like people
even getting banned even like the robert
malone guy getting banned off twitter or
alex jones it's like and you could hate
alex jones and be like [ __ ] yeah or
robert malone and be like good good that
he got he got um
banned off all his social media
platforms but again it comes back down
to the freedom of choice it's like
you're happy that they didn't give you a
choice like the option of making your
own decision in terms of if you want to
listen to this guy or not like in a way
they're they're still taking your
freedom away you know that's [ __ ]
weird to say hey
if flat earthers could have a [ __ ]
twitter
yeah
stupid but honestly though like that's a
really interesting case study because
like the fact that people think the
earth is flat
just shows that no matter and they they
they claim they have evidence right
which means it's not it's all wrong in
antarctica there's a wall bro that's not
this ice wall bro you haven't seen it
there's a large community of people that
really believe that the earth is flat
and they refuse to take any other proof
from
anybody that's giving like legit actual
proof
nah like no because my proof shows this
and i think that's what the problem is
no nobody can really tell the difference
between what real information is and
what actual
misinformation is well here's the
hypocrisy remember so everybody's golden
source of information people who are
hyper pro vaccine right is that their
golden source is the cdc well the cdc
also stated that well guess what guys uh
no more 10-day quarantine only five days
and then everybody who was so pro-cdc
they go oh the cds they're full of [ __ ]
it's like well hold on a second yeah
they flip bro yeah well hold on a sec
you were just literally singing their
praises saying that everything they say
is a hundred percent factual right but
when this became an inconvenience to you
suddenly they're not true right i don't
like that [ __ ] you better stick to
your [ __ ] guns because you were so
busy calling everybody a murderer now
you have to [ __ ] lie in the bed that
you made absolutely so how [ __ ] dare
you go against your golden source yeah
yeah makes no sense same thing with
pharmaceuticals pharmaceuticals used to
be the the devil the antichrist making
money off everything blah blah now it's
like oh we just got to believe
everything pfizer says yeah what the
[ __ ] are you talking about dude it makes
no sense if it was is robert malone if
he had a thick italian accent yeah
everybody wouldn't believe what he said
i thought i'd vote for him and then you
you give him a lob to [ __ ] italian
robert malone you're like robert malone
what is the better alternative than the
vaccine to solve kovit you just get a
[Laughter]
david show gets canceled for using
italian accents
hey i'll tell you it's all good though
nobody gets mad about the italian people
mexican people are the coolest
[ __ ] ever because they don't
give a [ __ ] they love it they don't care
they're like hey bro you sound just like
my cousin
you sound just like [ __ ] gordon
hey
come here he sounds just like you
yeah because you got the nuance bro you
got the nuance of the actual italian
accent you hang out with a lot of
italians or what no it's actually pretty
racial
it's okay though
but you know what i'll give you
people and like for example like the
french accent nobody cares because you
guys are cool like we're making fun of
cool it's like when people make fun of
white people like you guys are the the
dominant source of whatever yes so when
you're when you're imitating italian
accents it's like you're imitating
somebody that's known for being cool and
making dope food yeah right you're not
you're not oppressed yeah no one cares
and they're like yeah our food is pretty
[ __ ] good maybe a town people are
oppressed in america i don't know i just
made a general sweeping statement
i don't know
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast
we have deadbeat dad patrick over here
just kidding he's a great father i just
like to give him [ __ ] it's funny yeah
it's funny and then we have the virus
himself coveted
nick the ear if you're looking for
personal training how to lose weight
i've gained an exponential amount of
weight since i joined with him yeah
please hit up all of my protocols yeah
i'm taking you here
we'll see you all next time goodbye
goodbye